El pasado 10 de agosto una fatídica noticia
recorrió todo el mundo:
N1(Asesinan al candidato presidencial Fernando
Villavicencio tras un mitin en Ecuador. El
Confidencial)
Desde luego, no es la primera vez que en América
Latina se atenta contra un candidato presidencial:
En Colombia, en los años 80 y 90, se produjeron
los asesinatos de Jaime Pardo Leal, Bernardo
Jaramillo Ossa, o Luis Carlos Galán.
En México, más de lo mismo. Incluso hoy
muchos candidatos siguen sufriendo atentados
contra su vida. La inmensa mayoría, eso sí,
son candidatos locales. De hecho, en 2021
ni más ni menos que 27 candidatos a las elecciones
locales fueron asesinados en México.
Sin embargo, el trágico asesinato de Villavicencio
es especialmente importante porque refleja
la nueva realidad en la que vive Ecuador,
un país que ha pasado de ser uno de los pacíficos
de toda América Latina, a uno de los más
violentos. Ha sido un enorme cambio de paradigma
en muy pocos años.
De hecho, en cuestión de 4 años, Ecuador
se ha convertido en el tercer país más violento
de la América Latina continental. Sus tasas
de homicidios superan, incluso, a las de México
y Colombia. Una barbaridad.
Ahora son muchos los ecuatorianos que están
perplejos ante la deriva que ha tomado el
país. El asesinato de Fernando Villavicencio
ha sido una clara muestra al mundo de cómo
se están poniendo las cosas en este país.
Pero, ¿qué demonios ha ocurrido en Ecuador
para que se haya producido semejante deriva?
¿Quiénes son los principales responsables
de esta situación? ¿Por qué han asesinado
a Fernando Villavicencio? ¿Qué significa
realmente el trágico asesinato de este candidato?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T1(EL MÉTODO CORREA)
Si hablamos de regiones violentas en los últimos
años América Latina se ha llevado la palma.
Por supuesto, hay países en mejor y peor
situación. Y países como México, Colombia,
Brasil, Honduras o Guatemala no suelen salir
bien parados. Vamos, que suelen liderar el
ranking de los más violentos.
Ecuador, por su parte, ha vivido historicamente
una situación muy diferente. Ecuador no ha
sido un país excesivamente violento si lo
comparamos con sus vecinos regionales. Y no
lo ha sido por una razón principal: la reducida
presencia del narcotráfico en el país. Seguro
que no os sorprendo si os digo que negocio
del narco se desarrolló mucho más en su
vecino del norte, en Colombia.
Y, es veréis, aunque hay algunos pequeños
cultivos de coca en Ecuador, la realidad es
que no ha destacado nunca por ser un gran
productor como si lo es Colombia o su otro
vecino, el Perú.
De esta forma, Ecuador se ha limitado a ser,
especialmente desde principios del presente
siglo, un lugar de tránsito para todo tipo
de sustancias prohibidas procedentes de los
dos grandes productores que tiene como vecinos.
No obstante, y aunque el papel de Ecuador
haya sido fundamentalmente de tránsito, fue
justo desde principios de este siglo cuando
las pandillas, habitualmente vinculadas al
mundo del narcotráfico, comenzaron a extender
la violencia por todo el país.
Hablamos de pandillas como los famosos Latin
Kings o Los Choneros, dos grupos que llevaron
al país a un escenario en que cada año se
superaban los 2.000 homicidios. La histórica
tranquilidad de Ecuador se había terminado.
Sin embargo, a partir de 2007, la situación
cambiaría drásticamente. Llegó a la presidencia
uno de los principales líderes del llamado
“socialismo del siglo XXI”: Rafael Correa,
que daría un vuelco de 180º a la estrategia
de seguridad del país.
(La llegada de Rafael Correa a la presidencia
de Ecuador en 2007 comenzó con una de las
medidas más polémicas y revolucionarias
vistas en materia de seguridad. Correa rápidamente
comenzó un proceso de legalización de pandillas
como los Ñetas o los Latin Kings para que
dejaran de estar en la clandestinidad y pasaran
a ser “asociaciones juveniles” implicadas
en el proceso político.
Además, en 2011 lanzó su “Plan de Seguridad
Integral”, con el que pretendía dejar atrás
la mano dura que caracterizó a los gobiernos
ecuatorianos anteriores para centrarse en
la mejora de las condiciones educativas, sanitarias
y laborales para combatir el aumento del crimen.
Estas y otras medidas como la reforma del
Código Penal de 2014 lograron finalmente
que el número de homicidios cayera en los
años siguientes de forma sustancial, incluso
por debajo de la barrera de los 1.000 homicidios
en 2016. Es decir, una cifra en torno a los
5 homicidios por cada 100 mil habitantes.
Un nivel alto pero comparable al de países
como Argentina o Chile.)
Sin embargo, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
esto no duró demasiado. A partir del año
2018, en Ecuador se produjo una mezcla de
factores que acabaron por crear un cóctel
de violencia absolutamente explosivo.
Entre la elevada informalidad de la economía,
la precariedad y la pobreza, que se sitúa
en torno al 30% de la población, muchos grupos
criminales ligados al narcotráfico se abrieron
paso como una alternativa lógica a un modo
de vida estancado.
Por otro lado, la corrupción dentro del Estado,
también ha jugado y juega un papel muy importante
en toda esta historia. De hecho, en Ecuador
no es extraño encontrarse con noticias como
esta:
N2(Revelaron nexos entre marinos ecuatorianos
y cárteles del narcotráfico. La información
de inteligencia revelada por un medio ecuatoriano
demuestra los vínculos entre los miembros
de la Armada del Ecuador y los grupos del
tráfico de droga. InfoBae)
No obstante, hubo dos eventos muy específicos
que facilitaron la extensión del narco y
la consiguiente violencia. El primero de ellos
fue el cierre de la base estadounidense de
Manta en 2009 por parte del gobierno correísta.
La base de Manta era crucial para poder rastrear
el tránsito de avionetas del narcotráfico
dentro del país. Sin ella tuvieron vía libre.
Pero, seguramente, el factor más determinante
para el estallido de la violencia del narcotráfico
en Ecuador fue la firma del Acuerdo de Paz
entre las FARC y el Estado colombiano en 2016.
Y, os preguntaréis, ¿Las Farc? ¿Colombia?
¿Acuerdo de Paz? ¿Qué pintan aquí? ¿No
se supone que fue una buena noticia? Pues
más allá si el acuerdo fue más o menos
bueno, lo cierto es que tuvo importantes repercusiones.
Y es que, veréis, una vez que las FARC se
desmovilizaron, la importante posición que
esta organización ocupaba en la cadena de
producción y distribución de la cocaína
quedó huérfano.
Y, ¿qué creéis que sucedió? Exacto, que
varios grupos del narcotráfico, incluidos
muchos disidentes de las propias FARC que
no aceptaron el Acuerdo, comenzaron a forjar
alianzas con cárteles mexicanos y otras organizaciones
europeas para asumir el control.
El caso es que este auge de la violencia del
narcotráfico y las constantes luchas por
el control de las rutas ha llevado a que Ecuador
ya no sea únicamente un país de tránsito,
sino que ahora también es un enclave operativo
que resulta vital para el refinamiento, el
almacenamiento y la distribución internacional
de drogas.
Y, ¿sabéis quiénes han empezado a sacar
tajada de esta situación en el país? Exacto,
las pandillas. Pandillas, que por cierto,
son las principales responsables de la crisis
de seguridad que atraviesa el país desde
2021.
Y la pregunta es, ¿qué pasó en el 2021?
Pues… Veámoslo.
T2(PANDILLAS Y NARCOS)
Cuando uno se detiene a echar un vistazo a
la evolución que ha tenido la crisis de seguridad
en Ecuador, se da cuenta de una cosa: no es
que el actual gobierno de Lasso tenga, ni
mucho menos, toda la culpa de la dramática
situación actual, sino que la inacción del
anterior gobierno de Lenín Moreno fue devastadora.
Moreno, que como ya sabéis sucedió a Correa
en 2017, vio de forma prácticamente impasible
cómo el crimen se iba acelerando lentamente
durante toda su presidencia.
Es más, ¿sabéis qué hizo para intentar
combatir el progresivo aumento de la delincuencia
y la violencia? Pues, tomar medidas como esta:
N3(Extinción del Ministerio de Justicia preocupa
a defensores de derecho humanos. El Universo)
Efectivamente, lejos de aumentar el presupuesto
para luchar contra la creciente violencia
del narco, no se le ocurrió otra cosa que
eliminar el Ministerio de Justicia y reducir
el presupuesto penitenciario un 30%.
Y eso, eso, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
fue un tremendo error. Tras la adopción de
estas medidas, el Estado ecuatoriano comenzó
a perder el control sobre las prisiones inundadas
de miles de pandilleros.
Entonces, las cárceles comenzaron a convertirse
en los principales espacios de planificación
del crimen para las pandillas. En muchos casos
su centro de operaciones Y, de hecho, ¿sabéis
dónde comenzó la oleada de violencia que
más tarde se extendió por todo el país?
Exacto, dentro de una cárcel. Pero no tan
rápido, porque para poder entender el origen
de esta crisis de seguridad tenemos que detenernos
en un actor absolutamente clave: la pandilla
de Los Choneros.
(Fundada en los años 90 por Jorge Bismarck
Véliz España, conocido como “El Chonero”
por ser natal de la ciudad de Chone, esta
pandilla comenzó como el brazo armado de
un cártel colombiano. Más tarde, al comenzar
el siglo XXI, movió su actividad a la ciudad
costera de Manta, donde empezó a enfrentarse
con otras pandillas como Los Queseros para
controlar las rutas del narcotráfico en la
costa del Pacífico.
En 2010, tres años después de la muerte
de “El Chonero”, Jorge Luis Zambrano,
conocido como “Rasquiña”, pasó a liderar
la pandilla a pesar de estar entre rejas.
Desde entonces, Los Choneros comenzaron a
crecer hasta convertirse en la pandilla carcelaria
más importante de todo el país. Hablamos
de un grupo que está aliado al Cártel de
Sinaloa de Mexico y que desde el año 2007
llegó a dominar el tráfico de narcóticos
en el país.)
Ahora bien, sabéis lo que le acaba pasando
a todo imperio, ¿verdad? Todo lo que sube,
termina por bajar, y el caso de Los Choneros
no fue una excepción.
En diciembre de 2020, el líder de la banda,
“Rasquiña”, fue asesinado mientras disfrutaba
de su libertad tomándose un café en un centro
comercial.
Fue entonces cuando empezó de verdad el crecimiento
exponencial de la inseguridad en el país:
Tras su asesinato, las reyertas entre pandillas
dentro de las cárceles se convirtieron en
la norma habitual. Durante 2021 y 2022 las
masacres se sucedieron, dejando a cientos
de reos muertos.
Al final, los Choneros se vieron debilitados
por la rebelión de dos de sus subestructuras
conocidas como Los Tiguerones y Los Chone
Killers, su brazo armado. Poco a poco y pese
a los numerosos estados de excepción declarados
por el presidente Lasso, el caos se apoderó
de las prisiones.
Sin embargo, la violencia no se iba a limitar
exclusivamente a las cárceles:
N4(Ecuador sufre nueve atentados con explosivos
en un día. Euronews)
N5(Cinco muertos y 16 heridos en un atentado
con bomba en Guayaquil, Ecuador. EuropaPress)
Con semejante panorama, no nos puede extrañar
que Ecuador haya superado a México y a Colombia
en cuanto a muertos por cada 100.000 habitantes.
En total en 2022 se produjeron 4.500 homicidios.
Pero, ¿sabéis qué? Seguramente, el mejor
reflejo de toda esta desesperante situación
de inseguridad que está viviendo Ecuador
sea la ciudad costera de Guayaquil.
Conocida históricamente como “la perla
del Pacífico”, se ha convertido en una
de las ciudades más sangrientas del continente
y la más violenta de todo el país.
N6(Ecuador entra en la ruta latinoamericana
del narco: Guayaquil ya supera en crímenes
a Ciudad Juárez. El Español)
Guayaquil se ha convertido en uno de los centros
neurálgicos de la distribución de cocaína
y otros narcóticos a nivel internacional.
De hecho, las embarcaciones que transportan
estos productos no solo llegan a Centroamérica
y Norteamérica, sino que incluso llegan a
España y otras partes del norte de Europa.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, el hecho de que
sea uno de los principales puertos para la
distribución de droga, ha hecho que la ciudad
se convierta en un auténtico campo de batalla
entre pandillas y cárteles aliados.
De hecho, para que os hagáis una idea, más
de la mitad de los 145 atentados con explosivos
que se dieron en el país entre enero y agosto
de 2022 tuvieron lugar precisamente en esta
ciudad, en Guayaquil.
Pero, sea como sea, si algo está claro es
que la noticia que mejor represente la actual
situación de inseguridad y violencia que
vive el país es la del trágico asesinato
de Fernando Villavicencio.
Pero, ¿quién era Villavicencio? Y, sobre
todo, ¿qué nos muestra su asesinato?
Pues… Atentos.
T3(VILLAVICENCIO, LA PRUEBA DEL FRACASO DE
LASSO)
Como seguro que todos ya sabéis, el pasado
día 10 de agosto de 2020, el candidato presidencial,
Fernando Villavicencio, fue asesinado a tiros
tras salir de un mitin político
En el momento de preparar este vídeo, las
autoridades solo han podido detener a 6 colombianos
como responsables del atentado, pero no se
ha descubierto quién dio la orden, quién
puso precio a su cabeza…
Claro que, horas después del atentado, circuló
por redes un video que rápidamente se hizo
viral: era un video de una pandilla, conocida
como Los Lobos, que se atribuyó la autoría
del atentado.
C1(Nosotros, la organización “Los Lobos”,
asumimos la responsabilidad de los hechos
suscitados (el asesinato de Villavicencio)
la tarde de hoy, y se volverá a repetir cuando
los corruptos no cumplan su palabra”. Supuesto
comunicado de Los Lobos).
Los Lobos, que son la segunda mayor agrupación
delictiva de Ecuador, es una de las principales
pandillas que participaron en las masacres
carcelarias de 2021 y 2022.
Esta pandilla, que comenzó como una disidencia
de Los Choneros y que tiene vínculos con
el Cártel mexicano de Jalisco Nueva Generación,
ha ganado mucha relevancia desde el año 2021.
De hecho, cuando se unió a Los Chone Killers
y a Los Tiguerones en su rebelión frente
a Los Choneros, ganó un enorme peso en el
mundo del narcotráfico y la minería ilegal.
Esta organización llegó incluso a desterrar
a Los Choneros de Guayaquil.
Por eso, a primera vista uno podría asumir
rápidamente que Los Lobos fueron de verdad
los autores. Sin embargo, horas después de
que estos sacaran aquel video, otro video
se viralizó rápidamente. En este caso, los
hombres que aparecían en este decían ser,
a cara descubierta, los verdaderos Lobos y
negaban rotundamente la autoría del atentado.
(“Nosotros somos el GDO (Grupo de Delincuencia
Organizada) “Los Lobos”. No nos tapamos
las caras, nadie habla por nosotros y si cumplimos
con la paz. Aclaramos y rechazamos el asesinato
del candidato a la presidencia, el señor
Fernando Villavicencio. Comunicado de los
Lobos)
Por eso, en el momento en el que estamos preparando
este vídeo todavía no se sabe con exactitud
quién o quiénes estuvieron detrás del asesinato.
Lo que si sabemos es que Villavicencio ya
había denunciado una semana antes del atentado
que él mismo y su equipo de campaña habían
recibido claras amenazas de muerte de “Fito”,
el líder de Los Choneros, un tipo estrechamente
vinculado al Cártel de Sinaloa.
No obstante, a la espera de una investigación
más profunda, lo único que se conoce es
la implicación directa de aquellos 6 ciudadanos
colombianos.
Sin embargo, aunque aún no sepamos la autoría,
sí que podemos hacernos una pregunta, ¿por
qué Villavicencio y no otro candidato?
Pensadlo bien, a primera vista su asesinato
no tiene mucho sentido: las encuestas mostraban
una tendencia positiva, pero todavía estaba
lejos de la victoria, no parecía suponer
una amenaza política para nadie.
Sin embargo, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
a pesar de sus reducidas opciones de convertirse
en presidente de Ecuador, Villavicencio era
ya bien conocido por haber sido una voz especialmente
incómoda para el narcotráfico y los actores
corruptos del país.
La policía siempre saben dónde están, entonces
en mi gobierno vamos a actuar al revés. Quien
ataca primero no va a ser la delincuencia,
nosotros vamos a atacar. El mismo día que
yo me posicione voy a ordenar - obviamente
tendré que sacar a las manzanas podridas
que están en el interior de la fuerza pública
- ordenar, vamos a atacar. Sabemos las guaridas,
dónde están los capos del narco, vacunadores,
extorsionadores, sicarios… Vamos a sacarlos
de las guaridas y los vamos a someter.(Vamos
a combatir a narcotráfico como parte de una
estrategia transnacional la droga que sale
por este país el 90% sale por los puertos
de Guayaquil Así es que vamos a militarizar
los puertos de Guayaquil vamos a poner escáneres
en las principales vías vamos a crear una
policía antimafias para someter a estos grupos
terroristas)
(Su dura posición no era algo nuevo. Antes
de entrar en política, Fernando Villavicencio
se desempeñó como periodista independiente.
Un tiempo durante el cual investigó la corrupción
de gobiernos anteriores, en especial la del
ejecutivo de Rafael Correa. Durante su carrera
como periodista presentó numerosas denuncias
contra altos miembros del gobierno correísta,
e incluso contra el propio expresidente.
Crítico con Rafael Correa, fue sentenciado
en 2014 por difamación al expresidente, y
en 2016 fue nuevamente condenado a cárcel
por supuestamente revelar información confidencial
que había hackeada a la administración de
Correa. En ambos casos huyó para no cumplir
las penas impuestas y, a su vuelta a Ecuador
en 2017 tras la asunción de Lenín Moreno,
una de sus investigaciones permitió abrir
el proceso penal que terminó condenando al
expresidente huido a Bélgica a 8 años de
prisión por cargos de corrupción.)
En general, la gran mayoría de analistas
coinciden en que sus continuas denuncias anticorrupción
se habían convertido en una de las principales
amenazas para el funcionamiento de varias
organizaciones criminales y sus lazos con
altos funcionarios del gobierno. Esa muy probablemente
fue la causa de que lo matarán.
Al fin y al cabo, Villavicencio había prometido
una campaña sin cuartel contra el crimen
y el narcotráfico, se ha comprometido a depurar
a los funcionarios corruptos del gobierno
y de la policía e incluso había anunciado
la construcción de una cárcel de alta seguridad
en plena selva.
(Ahí se va a construir esta cárcel de alta
seguridad donde serán trasladados Los Capos
de la delincuencia organizada, narcotraficantes,
secuestradores, vacunadores… Ahí estarán
completamente aislados No hay posibilidad
de entrar por otra vía que no sea la vía
aérea
(Los primeros asustado con mi gobierno son
los jueces mafiosos. La justicia de este país
está tomada por mafias desde hace años.
Tenemos que sacar a las mafias de la justicia,
como lo vamos a hacer.)
Sin embargo, ¿sabéis que más prueba el
asesinato de Villavicencio, además del creciente
poder de las pandillas y el narco? Pues ni
más ni menos que el rotundo fracaso de la
estrategia de seguridad del presidente Lasso.
Como ya sabéis, la presidencia de Lasso ha
sido todo un calvario: un bloqueo legislativo
insalvable, la derrota en un referéndum que
el presidente convocó para intentar ganar
impulso político y la inevitable convocatoria
anticipada de unas elecciones que tendrán
lugar el domingo 20 de agosto. Apenas poco
más de 2 años después de haber llegado
al gobierno.
No obstante, no solo ha fracasado su plan
de reformas por falta de apoyos legislativos,
sino que también ha fracasado en su lucha
contra la inseguridad del país, que era otra
de sus grandes prioridades.
Ahora bien, ¿cuál fue exactamente su estrategia?
Pues, sencillamente declarar estados de excepción
dentro de las cárceles y luego estados de
emergencia para poder sacar al ejército a
las calles de ciudades como Guayaquil.
Y, la pregunta es, ¿tuvo éxito? Pues, por
desgracia, los datos dicen claramente que
no.
N7(Ecuador con récord de inseguridad en el
2023. Entre el 1 de enero y el 20 de marzo
de 2022, las autoridades contabilizaron 815
muertes violentas. Mientras que en los mismos
78 días de 2023 hubo 1.356. Esto supone un
incremento del 66.4%. La Hora)
Lasso llegó incluso a permitir la tenencia
y el porte de armas de uso civil para la defensa
personal. Una protección tan inútil como
inaccesible para la mayoría de los ecuatorianos.
Sea como sea, el caso es que, con carácter
genera, la estrategia de Lasso ha fracasado.
Pero no solo por las medidas que él mismo
ha decretado, sino también por los problemas
que las propias fuerzas de seguridad ecuatorianas
presentan.
La realidad es que las capacidades de investigación
de la policía no son precisamente las mejores,
y la rotación de altos mandos policiales
ha creado demasiada inestabilidad en los planes
de seguridad.
Y, por si fuera poco, luego está el tema
de las grandes sospechas de corrupción tanto
en el ejército como en la propia policía.
Ya lo veis, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
atrás quedaron los años en los que Ecuador
era un país relativamente pacífico.
Hoy este pequeño país latinoamericano, donde
cada vez tienen más peso las pandillas y
el narcotráfico, se ha convertido en uno
de los más peligrosos de la región y del
mundo. El asesinato de Villavicencio es la
mejor representación de esta tragedia.
Ahora la gran pregunta es si el nuevo gobierno
será capaz de reducir la criminalidad del
país o si por contra está verá sumergido
en una espiral de violencia de que sus vecinos
nunca lograron salir.
Pero llegados a este punto, la pregunta es
ahora para ti: ¿quién crees que ha sido
el responsable del asesinato del candidato
Villavicencio? ¿Cómo pensáis que puede
Ecuador superar su crisis de inseguridad?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo. Un
saludo y hasta pronto.